energy poverty in the uk is becoming a
growing problem
already 2.2 million people spend more
than 10 of their income on heat and
electricity
from april that number could triple as
the energy regulator off gem lifts the
cap that suppliers can charge consumers
bills could jump by half because of
runaway costs for natural gas
after april about 1 in 10 people may not
be able to afford to consistently heat
and supply electricity to their homes
it's particularly bad for people who are
on pre-payment meters which means they
top up as they want electricity and if
they can't pay the lights go out the
fridge goes off and they have to sit in
the dark in the freezing cold under
blankets
in the worst cases suppliers cut off
customers that are too deep in debt
the biggest portion of energy bills is
wholesale gas prices they're already
four times higher than they were a year
ago and are likely to stay there until
next winter
supplies of gas are tight because of
rising tensions between ukraine and
russia the main provider to
europe in some extreme cases charities
say that people are resorting to
desperate measures in order to light and
heat their homes
some people are using candles so that
they can see or even barbecuing in their
sinks which is extremely dangerous but
just so they don't have to turn on their
gas and power
[Music]